Aquaman in the lost kingdom is another
box office disaster for DC keep watching
to find out what all went wrong the DC
EU has finally come to an end wrapping
up a decade long chapter that never
really seemed to take off from the
so-called SN verse to Dwayne Johnson's
obsession with changing the hierarchy of
powers that rule the franchise the
series was filled with soaring highs and
brutal lows now with the long gestating
Aquaman sequel the franchise is done
calling it curtains to make way for
James gun's new and improved
interconnected universe and in true DC
fashion Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom
open the only way it could abysmally
released with little to no Fanfare James
ju's A Lost Kingdom opened to $27.6
million with a 3-day weekend according
to deadline that number which includes
Thursday previews is a significant drop
from the $67 million opening weekend
Hall the first Aquaman received in 2018
with a 3-day 27 million doll opening
Aquaman and the L Kingdom both the
second lowest opening for a DC film
coming in just ahead of the disastrous
$25 million Hall of Blue Beetle deadline
estimates that over the 4-day weekend
the one directed sequel will rake in
between $ 38 million and $39 million a
far cry from its predecessor's opening
this is no doubt a disappointment for DC
considering Aquaman is the franchises
highest grossing flick with receipts
totaling a whopping 1.14 billion dollar
beyond that this is DC's fourth bomb
this year leaving the franchiser future
profitability in doubt even with gun in
charge with a budget north of $200
million the lost kingdom will likely
fail to turn a profit superhero fatigue
is a buzzword that's consistently thrown
around to signal that audiences are fed
up with superhero Centric Blockbusters
and for a while it seemed like superhero
fatigue was more of a DC issue as
Marvel's films continued to prosper even
after the release of Avengers endgame
however over the last year the amount of
superhero related content has exploded
creating indifference among audiences
the proof is in the financial ping and
Aquaman in the lost kingdom is the
latest casualty in this viewers ship
assault over exposure is no doubt
leading to a lack of financial
prosperity no superhero film has crossed
the1 billion doll barrier since 2021
Spider-Man no way home have audiences
become inundated with too much superhero
content both on streaming and in
multiplexes or is this a bad movie issue
released during Peak superhero Mania the
first Aquaman offered something new and
it was warmly embraced by hardcore fans
and Casual viewers alike bringing home
an extremely solid a minus Cinema score
in short the picture was a crowd pleaser
something the lost kingdom isn't one
second trip to Atlantis feels disjointed
awkward and seems to lack a sense of
momentum which is probably why Warner
Brothers didn't lift the review embargo
until hours before the film's release
Lupa critic alist Ryder absolutely
decimated the film for being average
writing this generic but largely
functional tale suffers due to everybody
on screen clearly assuming this is the
end of the road or resigned to failure
even as they're shooting her for critics
across the board Aquaman and the lost
kingdom feels like a film that's simply
going through the motions offering
nothing new or engaging the same can be
said for audiences who awarded the film
of mediocre Beast Cinema score rating a
death sentence for a blockbuster prior
to its release Aquaman in the lost
kingdom was mired in controversy from
the Amber herd Johnny Depp drama to
reports that Jason Mamoa allegedly
appeared drunk on set James Juan's
latest was riddled with bad press that
simply couldn't be ignored a negative
narrative manifested around the picture
which no doubt seeped into the minds of
fans who likely knew that they were
about to witness a dir in December
coupled with the confirmation that the
last kingdom was going to be the last
flick in the DC EU it felt useless for
audiences to show up for what was
essentially an unceremonious end while
the behind thec scenes happenings on the
sequel are best left to speculation one
felt compelled to open up about how the
negative chatter surrounding the picture
was overwhelming and untruthful one told
Empire months before the film hit
multiplexes I've had to learn to be more
Zen in dealing with all the noise around
me for sure it's difficult because this
narrative has emerged that is not the
reality the noise is fun to write about
and it gets clicks but people don't know
the truth and by the time the picture
was about to be released it seems like
everyone had given up from not receiving
a red carpet Premiere to mimoa
explicitly telling Entertainment Tonight
that Aquaman's future is quote not
looking too good it appeared as if
Aquaman in the lost kingdom was dead on
a Ral and the receipts absolutely prove
it with a worldwide average of just
under $110 million with the 3-day
weekend the lost kingdom is a bitter and
disappointing end for the DCU the best
case scenario is that the film pushes a
$250 million barrier globally a number
it'll probably reach thanks to the
holidays but this one won't have those
Stellar legs because the product simply
isn't as compelling as its predecessor
now all eyes are on James G and Peter
saffron's Take On The World of DC which
will formerly kick off with 2025
Superman Legacy with no DC flakes set to
hit Cinemas until then he is hoping that
audiences will miss their quarter dose
of superhero theatrics and openly
embrace the new
regime